oh
in the eye you can still jump out yeah I
don't know I like that he's watching the
blade oh you want to step on that eye
I hate these kids
it wouldn't disgust me if you just went
deeper oh it's like a teddy bear in
there all that stuff it's like stuffing
still disgusts me even if it's shallow
he doesn't even like Flinch maybe you
don't feel pain no you definitely don't
feel pain you have a entire mushroom
grown out your eye mushrooms feel pain
can mushrooms cry oh now they can kind
of special effects by the way yeah good
great good practical effects oh
poor guy
oh that is that is him from why Lotus oh
my god oh I mean that's a lot
it seemed like a lot you don't want to
come in too little right yeah oh yeah no
you have to die you can't just go into a
coma it kind of looks like Joaquin
Phoenix there you just walk the line is
this Walk the Line
ah the French
I like the little bing bing and she has
to be classy
speech speech
[Music]
I like to make a toast
could it be enough
he's like putting all that strength and
lifting that glass
you gotta sniff it first
all right let's go
one up in big dog
okay why are you chugging your wine I
wonder
what a natural question Brandon well
he's showing off
why are there already pills in the
bottle
enough to kill a horse oh
oh
welcome back to New Rockstar The Last of
Us episode three long long time just
dropped in they went ahead and killed
two more people that I love and care
about and officially if this was any
other series I'd be done you'd be done
if this was The Walking Dead and they
kill him again I would have walked away
just like The Walking Dead but I love
the series too much and I care about
Joel and Ellie this is the break room
Our Daily Show that keeps you updated on
all the nerdy news that you guys need to
know about and today we're talking about
All About The Last of Us episode three
uh so grab a glass of pill wine and make
sure your fence is set to Electrify we
about to die
oh my God we're about to dive in I'm
Jessica Clemens I'm really sad uh here
with me today is Brandon Berry I'm also
sad
yeah this is how you uh fight it you're
like I fight it with happiness I fight
it with happiness I gotta say my wife
was very angry to see them both times at
least they went together they went
together at least they went together and
then I also have Anna van oh I'll keep
it positive Love Is Love
oh does love win does left win not here
I think I love one not the glove one
we'll talk about it we'll get into it it
doesn't survive it does sad sad sad uh
well as a reminder the first part of
this episode will be spoiler free we'll
just be talking about uh the three
episodes of the show we've seen so far
we recommend if you haven't played the
games to avoid reading the comments if
you don't want to be spoiled and if
you're in those comments don't spoil
things that's all we ask that's all we
ask there are a few foreshadowing
moments in this episode for folks that
have played the game and we'll be
leaving those out of the episode
recapping at the top and we'll cover
them at the end so when we get into
what's different from the game in the
show we'll warn you and when we get into
full spoilers for everything we'll warn
you about that but for now the episode
begins with Ellie and Joel 10 miles
outside of the Boston qz they've left
tests behind my podcast uh Joe's hand is
still healing which is something I love
about this show the injuries they don't
just go away after five minutes uh and
Joel says he's not looking for an
apology from Ellie and Ellie tells him
she wasn't planning not apologizing and
Tessa's death isn't her fault yeah
during that little moment in the woods
too something I love is that you see
Joel reach into a bag and eat some beef
jerky and the second it like touches his
tongue he like has a moment of like
because the first time we see him and
Tessie beef jerkies together
I love that moment too of where he's
like do I feed this dog he just throws
it at her
do I need to feed a child I don't
remember I threw it like she was a dog I
mean he's so angry when I love like the
anger they they both are feeling you
know she's mad at him he's mad at her
they're just angry and they kind of
squash the beat by just being like I'm
not gonna apologize I don't want to
apologize great great like they're both
the perfect amount of stubborn for each
other and I really like that uh also
maybe a small nod to the video games
Joel tells Ellie's shooting at someone
and missing happens uh more often than
you think which is like a great real
life moment of like yeah it's not like
the movies where you shoot someone once
and you hit them and they're dead like
it's very hard to shoot and shoot back
and there's drama going on I heard one
time about that how like how inaccurate
like how close you have to be to someone
with a pistol to actually like have a
good chance of hitting them it's not
great well if you have one if you have a
small caliber pistol and you're like
fire you could shoot someone a few times
and they're still alive you know it's
not it's not like the video games and
the movies folks uh Joe and Ellie walk
into a gas station Stash House us again
a very video game moment of searching
around all that Ellie finds a Mortal
Kombat 2 arcade game and mentions a
friend who quote new every everything
about this game this is likely a red
Ellie's friend Riley who will definitely
learn more about in a future episode
who's been name dropped before in the
very first episode uh so we'll get back
to that small correction that I have
today
listen no it's totally fine last last
show I was like I think we're going to
be getting the splash back soon I forgot
you can like see some of the episode
titles we got we got it yeah I think
it's coming later I think it's coming
later well it'll be soon enough yeah
soon enough I I also love like treating
Mortal Kombat 2's like storyline as like
the sacred text like oh it's just the
idea of this character is awesome uh
Ellie heads into the basement
insane and scores a box of tampons
before getting startled by an infected
trapped under a pile of rubble all I'm
saying is scan the room honey
all you saw was feet darkness and she
just plopped down and said oh one box of
tampons yeah yeah why I mean I guess the
idea that it's sealed there's probably
nothing I'll have in there but right but
you don't know she drops down and
immediately like looks to the wall at
the right and I'm like scared to them
well she didn't have anything but that
knife too so I was like bro what are you
thinking Brave courageous yes dumb also
yes don't do that so she comes across
this infected trapped under a pile of
rubble uh and Ellie goes full psycho
mode and slices into the infected head
slowly before stabbing it to death uh
what can we like what it seems like
they're trying to make her a little
sociopathic in this show which is kind
of left field from the gate like I don't
know why they're giving her so many like
I think it's more I think it's more so
just looking at like I'm not afraid of
you and then seeing like this is What
You're Made Of is a funny she's
entranced by this because that violent
thing I this is also just me taking on
like if I if it killed everyone I knew
if it's killing everyone in the world I
was born into this world I'm gonna show
you that I'm not afraid of you but also
like she gets bitten and she doesn't get
affected so she's just like I I bring up
a great Point Jess she's born into this
world and we heard Tessa in the first
episode like when she's talking about
the kids who jumped her she's like you
know people born young people born after
the outbreak they don't know how to
negotiate like their whole life is
violence and fear and monsters like
she's never been outside before she's
never been in the woods before but she
sees the airplane we'll get out in a
second right so like the fact that she
can the only time she's been close to an
infected that we know of it was a very a
devastating moment in her life and we'll
learn all more about that but like she's
able to be up close and examine one
fedra in their school hasn't really
taught them much about these things or
what they've told them is BS so I think
she's interested and she kind of wants
to know and you know as a kid you you
get close to snakes because they're
dangerous and your parents told you not
to but you want to be close to them but
do you dissect them
I wouldn't call it dissected it's more I
think it's genuinely just like I'm not
afraid of you and this is a monster but
she is I think she's not afraid but she
is very afraid but like this is her
chance to get as close it's going to the
zoo and getting in the lion cage with a
piece of glass when she kills a small
animal then oh okay I mean this isn't a
standalone thing in the first episode
when Joel's beating the [__] out of that
guy friend language uh she's also she's
like yeah so I don't this might be I
think yeah I think I disagree
there was also a great story that was in
the uh podcast about this episode or
about uh episode two uh where the
creators talked about like a backstory
they were gonna have a test where she
had to like leave her son behind who was
infected in the basement and couldn't
kill him uh that's that could have been
her son that could have been tested son
who got out and got trapped in there I
don't know possibly who knows people
look very um specific I wonder yeah yeah
would you think that was a guy who like
was hiding out down there and then
somehow got infected by the fungus and
then the collapse and he stuck down he's
like oh God oh God I'm Gonna Change I'm
Gonna Change
honestly at first I thought it might be
frank but that was kind of been wrong
that was proven wrong it looks specific
that would have been interesting if they
did that to Frank uh Joel stashes his
assault rifle saying there's not a ton
of ammo out there for it Ellie just like
in the games ask for a gun again
wouldn't you I would
constantly I absolutely would be I was
like yeah you got to protect yourself in
this I guess as they leave the stash
house they pass a crash plane and a mass
grave of bodies that were killed by
fedra to better control the population
and it's horrible yeah it's that was
that was a great moment and a reminder
for all of us as we complain about going
through the airport and the process and
it sucks we get to fly through the sky
folks what an amazing feat what a what a
cool thing it's a flying sometimes crash
and die well it happens less often you
think driving in a car is much more
dangerous than flying in an airplane
there's a lot of cars
Joel mentions the goddamn pants while
describing how the outbreak most likely
began sounded real familiar except for
the whole biting thing yeah I loved this
kind of explanation of it because it is
like the question of like how did this
outbreak happen so fast but the idea
that one single batch that is put in
shelves around the world around the same
time that kind of explained it really
well I like that that made a lot of
sense yeah he like kind of chokes up
before he says
tough stuff well it's 2003 again folks
we've gone back in time uh we meet Bill
played by Nick Offerman a disaster
prepper I mean survivalist hiding in his
basement while Frederick clears his
neighborhood one thing that was
interesting about this to me Federal was
set up pretty quick uh in the games well
in the show because this is three days
after the initial outbreak it's like
September 30th oh yeah 2003 when the
rounding up people and the sign says
fedra at the bottom so has the
government collapsed that fast that
fedra has formed and they've already
printed signs that say fedra I mean
that's a good fascist takeover to get a
logo together I think it's also the the
quicker you got it you guys you gotta
you gotta get into it you have to clear
out you gotta bomb things you gotta fix
it so I think they just immediately
assembled a team because most probably
half of government was already taken
over or that's what was fetra always
lurking underneath oh God the thin
veneer of our military was always there
ready to go when Nick Offerman says the
government's Nazis he's referring to
Federal yeah they were always there
operation Jade uh Hound or whatever it
was called look it up they're coming for
us anyways uh we get another Cameo from
serious Creator Craig Mason as one of
the soldiers yelling no sir we're in the
basement now no one here
um so Craig Mason all over the show and
bill says not today you knew World Order
Jack boot [__] uh which we included in
this recap because it's the best line on
television so far this year it's early
in the year but so far it's it's taking
the cake uh bill goes to town literally
uh building the neighborhood of his
prepper dreams complete with booby traps
electric fences running hot water and
electricity okay during all this
and when they're showing the whole Mass
grave thing
listen the amount of gay symbolism made
I would say peppered but it's like giant
Boulders of pepper that they threw on
there there was the rainbow flag that
she was swaddling the baby and that was
the first thing we saw the fabric had
little rainbows on it yeah exactly and I
was like oh you know cute knot
when Nick Offerman or
bill is reading all the things he
carries this giant box of wine that just
says gay Miss and I literally have in my
notes all caps not the game is why they
gave us that's a Camus but does it says
was this um
wow I hope so because that was too
awesome
I really hope it does not say gamers
because I honestly I was like that is so
on the net I mean they're like are you
sure the Linda ronstaff yeah the Linda
okay to be fair
like I'm not working at work at 4 20.
you didn't have a screen right sometimes
hard to see but again we'll double check
on that I'm keeping it and keep it in if
it says okay it's fine it's fine it
should say game us then my favorite wine
gaming barrels of 13 years uh four years
later and Frank has found himself in one
of Bill's traps bill but I think this is
the Trap we see Bill building in that
kind of sequence we see him like looking
over some chicken wire and covering with
mud I like to imagine that was the exact
same track I I would say also like Bill
had a plan he was ready like what
happened he's been waiting for this day
and knew exactly what to do these people
are my favorite people in series when we
did it in Cloverfield Lane I was like
yeah this man hat is prepared but also
we should be worried that this man is
prepared I mean both of your examples of
people not great but no it feels better
than that oh well John Goodman there's
some survivalists that are fine but I
was nervous about Bill ever yeah uh Bill
test Frank for the infection with one of
federal scanners because he got all hold
of one and the results are clean how did
you get that you probably do you think
he killed a federal agent to take it uh
I like to imagine he found a dead one
already but he probably also killed a
fair
Ness against them they're not great
they're not great uh Bill Cooks Frank
the meal of a lifetime I would never get
this meal even before this uh and it's
uh it's a lifetime impairs his rabbit
with a how do you say that a Beaujolais
are the first scrapes of oh there's a
Beaujolais Nouveau which is the first
Grapes of the Season that they don't
allow to age they bottle it immediately
uh well it's actually very sweet it's
like it comes out it's the first grips
of the season and like I usually eat it
very early in the year when they harvest
or late early fall is when it comes out
uh but this wasn't a Beaujolais Nouveau
this was just a regular Bourgeois oh my
God okay I have a drinking problem no
you're fine we looked up this exact
bottle of wine and it cost about ten
dollars also if John was a coward and
the thumb for this video isn't what's he
cooking with Bill send a letter to your
rock stars yeah what was it cooking but
who knows how many credits that thing is
worth in the apocalypse yeah also it
doesn't mean is not great one if it's
just ten dollars by the way the man
knows how to Ace a first I mean he Nails
it when he spins the plate so that it
the Perfect Image is is placed in front
of Frank like that's that's a man with
teeth well let me get into he's got a
charger plate too let's get into how
they kind of went downhill for a minute
after lunch break sits down at Bill's
mother's untouched piano and starts
playing a truly horrendous version of
Linda ronstadt's a long long time uh
it's so bad I love that they both sing
very poorly in this episode it doesn't
matter at all it's very scary I mean
Phil has so much heart and I love that
bill cannot stand what this man is doing
to this song and he's like all right
well show me what you got and it's so
heartful and tender nick offerman's uh
just launched a tour he's going across
the us right now he's going to do a
little show that has like song he's
gonna sing in it and stuff like check it
out check out his website it's a free
promo for you nick uh but that moment ah
so tender so tense the whole time like I
was because they still don't I mean
these are two strings managers who have
met you know Bill's got a lot to protect
here he's very scared and he's like
slowly letting this man in let him
shower was very interested in the shower
that was happening uh but yeah this
moment the piano was so sweet and if it
sings better than me what a beautiful
man you sing very well doing oh
Bill Cuts Frank off seemingly reminded
of an old lover they kiss and Bill
finally tells Frank his name Frank tells
Bill to take a shower because
one thing I know with this kiss they
framed it very similarly to Tess yeah
and last time they did that kiss and
that setup it meant certain Dooms so I
was like oh I wonder if that was a
little breadcrumb that this is not gonna
be great alive ending for these two yeah
the last kiss we saw was the kiss of
death and see at this point too oh I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna spoil anything
yet I just want to say what I would give
what I would give to see this episode of
someone who hasn't played the game
because it was colored it was tinted the
whole thing was tinted for me yeah yeah
yeah my wife had never has never played
the game uh and she asked me is this
like the video game and I said
we'll talk about that more Frank plays
his cards Ryan tells Bill he's only
getting that good good if he stays for a
few that was a smart move a very smart
move uh yeah yes it was yes it was we
didn't talk about this we didn't talk
about this I would have done the exact
same thing uh days turned to months and
months turned to years that jump cut
from like
so three years later and Frank just
wants to paint the goddamn neighborhood
Bill what do you guys save paint for
what's the paint gonna be he said No
One's Gonna Come Up Resource Management
uh and he also wants to have a few
friends over which bill is just like not
having uh but what uh I think we can all
empathize with that argument I was gonna
say y'all two have been very like
survivalist minded like realist If This
Were The Apocalypse if you were building
that situation and your partner was like
I want to start having people over right
would you be opposed to them it's a bad
idea it's a horrible idea but I know I
would be frank that's like I'm you get
to build things that keep us safe I
don't do those things you before this
you were doing this I just did I was a
teacher like I would probably be like
let me paint the mailbox but let people
in I'd go crazy I'd be weird uh so if
you're keeping track to all the time
jumps uh this is seven years into the
pandemic it's 2010 and Joel and Tess
visit Bill and Frank for the first time
so good to see Tess alive again young
Tess looking great young Joe also
looking great he's about 46 43 here he
was 36 in 2003 at seven years later I'm
an actor
he's not in the script I can't do it
this is uh this is a very useful
timeline info for Joel and Tessa's
relationship to know where they're at
they're working together they're
smuggling they're getting it done uh
it's clear now that like Tess has been
talking to Frank over the radio again
Frank talking to people over the radio
without bills knowledge is a little iffy
that's really dangerous I am a bill side
there uh we now know Joel and Tommy
probably got to Boston pretty early on
and at least met Tess around the same
time okay during that dinner party as
well uh or lunch luncheon
I did notice I was looking at their
plates and I I saw an interesting detail
Frank's was completely empty okay
Tessa's was almost completely empty
Joel's mostly full and then bills was
like he had barely touched his food and
I think that this is uh sort of showing
their comfort levels like Joel and Bill
who are the most reserved like unsure of
each other who should be ready to draw
their guns at any time are like barely
touching their food not eating anything
and then Frank and Tessa were just like
oh it's a great luncheon or have already
chowed down now because like Joe there
is like this could be poison they're
gonna like they're trying to poison us
so they can put us in the basement and
cut us up and because they're cannibals
or at the very least they're all sitting
there with a gun well and Bill is like I
don't have the second I bend over to
take a bite of food this Joel is going
to kill all of us right like they're
here to just take over meanwhile Frank
and Tess who have probably each been
talking to over the radio without their
partner's consent or like yeah we're
good friends we're getting along fine
what's everyone's big deal that was a
great tense Legend I love that line
where Joel is like get the gun out of my
[__] face and Bill respects that he's
like this is a good man Joel uses his
construction background to convince Bill
he needs to fix up his fence we also
learned that it was Frank's idea to use
codes on the radio that came back and
they resolved that that radio thing very
well in this episode I love that another
three years past bill and Frank have
fixed up their fence and Frank's shows
Bill his little strawberry
they almost got really into the
strawberry
both my wife and I were like
and strawberries only bloom once and
then you have to replant them that's
very dangerous how dare you that on the
strawberries I know just got so excited
about that as soon as the strawberries
haven't I said ruin the strawberry
Bill gives a little
and giggle
[Laughter]
a little can you do it please
uh and this is the moment I knew they
were [__] dead no Jess why can't we
have nice things why can't we have nice
things bill in that so so sorry I just I
literally just remembered in that
conversation they have the little
off-handed comment at the time of like I
like you being older than me when Frank
says that to Bill a little bit of
foreshadowing for how you feel so
useless I was gonna say useless I think
it's those little line when he was like
uh I was fine here by myself I always
felt safe until you showed up because
now he has something to protect
I'll never have that important dialogue
over strong I'll never have that oh I
know destroy the strawberries roll in it
put your backs in it sometimes later
Raiders attack you guys uh bill is
standing in the street firing at the
Raiders like an idiot alone no cover and
that's why I get shot yeah and takes a
gunshot straight to the abdomen he tells
Frank to call Joel expecting not to make
it bill is so cute he had a plan for
this exact moment so Frank would be
taken care of in case anything happened
I love that Frank is just like not
having it he's like hyper focused he's
like he's keeping Bill talking but he's
like Bill's like the fences you have to
switch the generator every three days
and he's like just shut up I'm getting a
bullet out of you my guy it was a a
great writing yeah great writing for
them a great way to convey how much
people can find love especially in a
darkest moment and then just find their
partner their soulmate actually in real
life yeah so sure like he died though
they did make it too yeah we'll get a
slow Fade to Black the voices are kind
of fading but Bill survives folks it's
now another 10 years later and we've
caught up to present day it's 2023 or
close to present day Frank is taking up
painting uh and unfortunately has some
sort of incurable disease that keeps him
in a wheelchair I kind of think this is
potentially a mess yeah maybe my mom has
Ms and I so I know a little bit about it
it tends to it's a uh what's the word
degenerating disease is it degenerative
degenerative disease exactly
um and so I could see him slowly kind of
losing his yeah he seems to be the
ability to walk his arms you know you
see half of the painting is really good
you have well you have the moment where
he's like he's painting I also when uh
bill is putting Frank to bed you see in
the background and you see it kind of
throughout the rest of the episode you
can see paintings from before his
accessibility of pain and he's always
painting Bell oh it's great uh an easy
to miss detail that I really like right
at lunch bill asked Frank if he's taking
his pills yet Frank had him because he
was already planning to make it through
the week like he's kind of thinking
through this already uh and I was
waiting for Joel to bust through the
door to grab that pill bag and lick it
oh my God
show one show I beg of you Brandon
Joel's got a pill problem someone's
getting branded off his pills Frank
declares today is the last day and Bill
quickly Cycles through all the stages of
grief and just like ah heart-wrenching
scene Frank has the whole itinerary plan
including tying the knot with Bill and
having a wonderful dinner uh with a side
of euthanasia they even go to the
boutique that Frank demanded to fix up
uh to get their tuxes and everything and
get married Bill and Frank's last day is
set to Max Richter's on the nature of
daylight more on that in the middleman a
moment the couple gets married and
finishes dinner bill has dosed the
entire bottle of wine so they can spend
eternity together in their bedroom which
I really agree with because Franco's
like I Want To Die In Your Arms and all
I was thinking about was like five
minutes after that where Bill has to be
like yeah
I know but then you gotta bury it and
then you're supposed to live on without
them you can I'm sure they probably
talked about what to do with the body
off screen it wasn't going to add to the
storyline they do go to bed and in their
story together closed in the room just
just I mean
so good
so good Jill and Ellie arrive at Bill
and Frank's after needing to enter the
gate code to get in Joel immediately
knows something a little off Ellie
flowers the flowers
shut up don't talk to me the flowers I
remember after this episode I
immediately texted John and said I'm not
going to be on it I was like I can't
talk about this I really went out and
watered the flowers on my balcony Carrie
said what are you doing I was like they
have to know we're alive Carrie
Ellie finds the no bill has left along
with a car key and then no bill tells
Joel that he was happy everyone uh had
died but he was wrong saving Frank
became his purpose and Joel knows Ellie
is now his purpose Joel crumbles up the
note seemingly still not ready to take
on this responsibility he and Ellie load
up the truck with supplies the radio is
playing 80s music which tells Joel and
Ellie that the trouble they heard in
episode one was just because Bill set
the playlist to play if he didn't reset
the system for a few weeks which I was I
was wondering how they're going to wrap
up that detail and that was nice it was
very great yeah Ellie snags a bunch of
toilet paper as you should and a gun
from a drawer the same gun Frank picks
up as they're rated earlier in the
episode and I bet that won't come back
she's gonna tell it's all about she's
been wanting that gun he's gonna do that
and it also maybe has like two bullets
uh after a shower Ellie changes into her
outfit it from the game the red shirt we
made it in this case red shirt being a
good thing yeah yeah I got the they hit
the road and Ellie grabs the cassette
tape labeled mix for Bill
and throws on Linda ronstadt's long long
time one final tribute to Frank and
Bill's relationship also Joel knows all
the words to it uh I love that this is
the last song
that Linda Ronstadt was the secret code
for I'm gay you gay we get together
let's be gay uh I don't know anything
goes in there anything goes in the qz uh
I also like that Joe was like no this is
a good [__] Song Ellie get your [__]
together okay let's go uh I love that
this is the last song they were
listening to on this mix I mean just uh
Bill and Frank guys the two leave the
neighborhood and head West to Wyoming as
we pull back on an open window with
curtains blowing in the breeze a common
the last of a site that it was often on
the load screen you would see it in the
game in novels it means sex so anything
happens anything else I also really like
that this moment was it was what Frank
had envisioned early on where he's like
someday we're gonna have friends and
they're gonna come visit in this final
shot we were all kind of worried we were
about to see a puddle on the bed but
what the final shot was there was
nothing in the shot that indicated the
world they live in now it was their
friends driving away and pulling through
an open window and there was no in fact
I guess there was no burning there was
no federal
just pour itself
also uh when they get in the car it's
Ellie's first time in the car she makes
a comment that it's like a spaceship
which is just a cute little nug Sally
wants to be an astronaut she doesn't
know what a seatbelt is which I thought
was adorable safety is so cute I forgot
that she was born in the time of the
pandemic and I kept being like why is
Jack's so reckless and then I genuinely
was like oh I forget
yeah so speaking of that final song that
plays I want to talk about the music in
general in this episode because
everything had I feel like so much
meaning so you talked about long long
time uh they play that on the piano in
the beginning it's what the song ends
with and I thought this was just like
the perfect bookmark because looking at
the lyrics it it starts with love will
abide take things in stride sounds like
good advice but there's no one at my
side which is you know I obviously bill
is longing for companionship when he
meets Frank he's feeling he's been alone
for all these years but then it ends
with uh some of the lyrics at the end of
the song or I've done everything I know
to try and change your mind and I think
I'm gonna miss you for a long long time
and I know
it's with Bill and Frank but also with
Joel and Terrence like it's just like a
oh it's the perfect bookend song
um also in the games the song that uh
normally plays in the car when they pop
in the cassette tape is alone in forsink
alone in forsaken by Hank Williams which
is also a song about someone that he
loves leaving him and him being really
sad about that but the biggest Downer of
this whole episode is while they're
having the Montage final day the final
day Montage was on the nature of
Daylight by Mac Richter and they have to
stop using the song in movies because I
will cry every time they used it in a
rival they used in Shutter Island you
gotta stop please the sooner that song
Started I was like I know I've heard
this one before yeah it's it's a very
famous song but what I also think is
super interesting is that in Shutter
Island especially uh they combine it
with um Dinah Washington a song This
Bitter Earth she sort of sings The
Melody do you know Washington Dina
Washington thank you so much I've only
ever seen it written uh so she sings
that Melody over the the song okay
um and some of those lyrics which might
be coincidental but I think it's cool is
uh it includes such bangers as what good
is love that no one shares and today you
are Young Too Soon you're old which I'm
like
whoa full circle full circle into the
story and then just a couple more uh
little little tidbits the music at the
beginning when uh bill is stealing all
that stuff stealing you know
Scavenging Scavenging
um is that one of the songs that plays
is I'm coming home to stay by Fleetwood
Mac and I think maybe this is reaching I
think they chose this song Because
Stevie Nicks is a well-known gay icon oh
okay and I think it's another little
like
along with you know game of swine and
the rainbow thing I I think they might
Stevie Nicks Stevie Nicks made game of
wine she is a witch she's a witch yeah
maybe he's also a witch
and then the other song that plays is
White Room by Cream which doesn't have
any lgbtqa plus ties as long as I know
white room by Cream
Jess not this show not this [__] I'm
just saying I'll take one ticket
or I'll wait in this place where the Sun
never shines waiting this place where
the Shadows run for themselves and again
I just feel like these lyrics are really
tying into them
all those songs played in that one
episode yeah that's insane I mean a very
song Heavy episode really I mean an
incredible episode I think the biggest
question I really have come out of this
episode I want to ask you you two smart
people Craig Mason on the Last of Us
podcast talks about the theme of this
show being love is dangerous he brought
this up in the first episode of the
after Show podcast check it out if you
haven't already specifically he's
referencing this to Joel's relationship
with both his daughter and Ellie that
like love is a great thing but sometimes
it can be very dangerous it can put you
in Danger episode 3 was mostly con a
contained Love Story between Bill and
Frank so what I'm wondering is this show
going to show us a bunch of different
portrayals of The Power of Love The
Power
of Love are we gonna do a bunch of
different portrayals of The Power of
Love or do we just get this episode to
have some hope in the apocalypse because
there's been so much like Downer in
these first two episodes that this third
episode was like supposed to be here's a
good love story how do you guys
interpret the way they're using love in
this episode
I wouldn't I think that there is still
uh in this episode a dangerousness to
the love that is portrayed I don't think
Bill would have ever put himself at risk
or sacrifice himself or on off himself
uh if if Frank wasn't in his life when
you say put himself at risk that moment
during the raid when he's in the middle
of the street shooting and Frank
literally has to pull him back he put
himself in extreme danger probably for
Frank and the thing is if he that's the
hard part because love makes you do
crazy things as Brandon she's a he's a
maniac and Carrie's perfect
um but it's also like he didn't think
that if he dies he did have a plan yes
but Frank didn't know that plan yet
right if Bill would have died on the
street while Frank was yeah yes he got a
headshot and then you just left him to
die as well because Frank doesn't have
the same survivalist Instinct as Bill
does he's gonna waste all the paint
immediately if it was me absolutely the
entire Street would have been pink but
um I think and also it's interesting
because it's like yeah love and what way
right it is physical and is metaphorical
right so it's like uh what Frank and
Bill had was like physically love was
very dangerous doing all these acts was
very dangerous letting this man into
your home not knowing what he could have
been bringing is very dangerous like
people are following him what happened
after that but for Ellie and Joel it's
like you can't get too close you can't
do all these things what happens when
you're like if they do even like each
other it's like they're so guarded
they're not willing to like like each
other and I think theirs is more of a
metaphorical right now than it is a
physical yeah yeah and I I kind of agree
with you and I like I think Bill and
Frank's relationship it was a great
representation of love and how powerful
that is and what two people can be for
each other but I also found it very
dangerous because they did not adapt to
their surroundings right they didn't
adapt what was happening to the world
they walled themselves off literally and
stayed the way they had been yes they're
living the life of luxury with hot water
and fresh food and all that stuff sounds
great but like if that falls apart when
Joel shows up and it's like yo this fan
Ain't Gonna Last and like you guys can
might be in your little Paradise but
there's gonna be Raiders coming and like
they're gonna keep trying to get through
and like you having this little Hideaway
of love it might be nice for YouTube but
it's very dangerous and you're not
adapting to the world around you you're
just actively trying I think they
started once Joel said that I assume
they were just running out of resources
right like it's like you have and also
he only they don't have the right fences
at the Home Depot and also the Home
Depot was farther yeah it wasn't in the
same area so I was like oh and I was
also like who knows what's at the Home
Depot already people that have been
turned and then on top of that I was
like you are gonna eventually use
Everything At Home Depot yeah you know
there's gonna be at least one infected
guy with an orange apron he's like I
know more than you hi there is there a
project you're working on I know more
than you I did appreciate like the the
way the show acknowledges like at least
batteries can't just sit around for 20
years it'll be good you know he had
taken apart a battery with the sulfuric
acid in the fridge so that like it had
to be put together again I love that
appreciate that I hate when shows are
like oh the car's been sitting here for
20 years and it starts up and drives
away it's okay
it was never okay but to answer your to
answer your question or the second part
of the question I do think that they are
going to be exploring throughout this
whole season different instances of Love
different types of Love they're gonna
build it up show you different aspects
of it and I
have to we've seen three episodes now
where they then tear it down so it
doesn't last roller coaster yeah what
happens when you meet the people that
are married that hate each other yeah oh
that's true yeah uh yeah because Bill
could have gone on living without Frank
but he chose to kill himself because of
love like he was like I don't want to be
without this person and Bill's a guy
who's well adapted to surviving in this
atmosphere and like he even was like
nope love is so powerful it's going to
take me out and you know Joel's
unrequited unacknowledged love for Tess
is dangerous too because Elliot was
afraid to read in the letter Tess's name
thinking it might set Joel off well he
said never never said oh that's right
never say her name again never say her
name that's why he that's why I was like
Ellie kind of did it in a dick way of
being like
yeah he's not so scared because like
this was where she was supposed to know
and now this is gone too Tessa's gone
Bill and Frank are gone and I'm still
stuck with Joel who hates me is throwing
beef jerky at me what am I gonna do uh
where are we going get the battery uh
well we have lots we're talking about
this episode but first we want to remind
you to check out new rockstarsmerch.com
where you can always grab the latest and
greatest merch from new rockstars and we
have some exciting news right now you
can grab this incredible The Last of Us
inspired shirt lost in the darkness
inspired by the games and images from
the show grab yours before the season
ends and get ready for season two
because it's coming folks it's official
you can also grab shirts hoodies hats
and pins and so much more featuring the
new rockstars logo and very very soon
we'll have our Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania inspired merch for sale just
in time for the premiere you don't want
to be caught at the premiere without it
keep an eye out for that also if you
know the outbreak happens tomorrow you
want to be rocking a new Rockstar's
merch when you're shambling around
mushrooms growing out of your face
uh
one second one I don't I have no idea a
baby a baby lost in the pandemic uh so
be sure to check out the website for
that and as always support the channel
and check out new rockstarsmerch.com
another question I have for you both a
very cynical take on this episode is
that Frank is a bit of a prisoner in
this relationship you know uh what a
prison to be in but like he doesn't you
can't leave right Joe makes the argument
that they won't be safe in their
compound because they're unable to adapt
to the realities of this new world what
are we talking about Frank and Bill get
their happy ending but do you think this
is a good idea for them what would you
do in this situation would you stay in
this compound that you've like built up
absolutely I also was like uh I would
fake being in love with someone
immediately
yeah you think he faked it no I don't
think no Oh I thought you were throwing
that out there and I was like I don't
know if I'm ready
a year or less than a year or a year
plus like a little bit of time has gone
by you know I think I think the way I
read it because wait keep going well we
had this conversation in my household
wait a minute it was like Frank faking
in his attraction to bill at first
because I mean you're getting
electricity water security food you know
Nick Offerman it's not a bad looking guy
smells bad clearly he's got to take a
shower but uh I was very skeptical of
Frank's intentions at first yeah it was
well because I mean Frank says he was
with 10 people and now they're gone so
he clearly killed those 10 people
yeah yeah and I the moment in the hole
where they're kind of they don't see
each other yet and they're like do you
have a gun and he's like unsure if he
should say if he has a gun or not when
they'll ask they can't see each other
yet they don't they can't size each
other up but you know
is Frank being very manipulative there
in a weird way I don't know I didn't
think it was until they he just fell
into a booby trap I would be afraid I'm
gonna be eaten by someone I think it was
also I mean you're already in the booby
trap so there's no use in you lying
about anything you're already taken uh
it wasn't until you started playing the
piano Nick Offerman I was like oh he's
gonna hit him over the head I was like
he's gonna beat him over there
I was like easy easy do it easy done
easy come easy go I think
you know just like do I eat this food
much like we talked about Joel is this
poisoned like Frank was like do I eat
this I don't know and when he was kind
of when uh Bill's still in the kitchen
and like he's kind of scoping around the
house and he notices like the dust which
I thought was very interesting in his
mind he's thinking this is a man who's
very capable who's taking care of things
but he's allowed this house that clearly
wasn't decorated by him to kind of
settle in dust what is happening here
what's going on like there's both little
things they notice about each other that
puts them on edge but Linda Ronstadt
brings them together it kind of also it
helps flesh out the character because
later he wants to like he he very much
cares about the appearance yeah and
things like that I complimented each
other very well what I thought you were
going to say about the piano scene was
it wasn't until a tear rolled down for
Frank's cheek that I was like wait does
he not have ulterior motives like I
don't know the actor was playing it's so
oddly sketchy I felt I mean well I think
both I think they're smartly both on
edge you know it's like I mean he was
Frank was willing to get into a shower
strip down and get into a shower and be
in a locked room with only one way out
right so he trusted bill or he was at
least we're like well if I'm gonna die
at least I get a shower out of this
that's the thing they both each had just
good motives but also motives would be
like
I I don't know what to do what's the
next step there is no like actual like
what's the next step you just have to
keep going with it and be like I hope he
lets me stay oh coming back I don't I
hate that word hostage I don't think he
was a hostage
he's literally in a cage
in your question did you not have the
word hostage tell me a gilded cage I
don't remember I've said something sure
well neither of them were Hospital
prisoners it's a gilded cage this is
what discussion is all about yeah
we're gonna go Frank there's some pizza
out there where are you gonna go buddy
never Nick Offerman was oh I don't know
why I keep calling him Nick Offerman and
Bill was never he was never using
Frank's safety against him that was
never the case do you think at one point
they had a fight where they're like I'm
leaving well where are you gonna go
Frank in the hole
[Applause]
honestly the best part about being in a
fight there is like no I'm just gonna go
to the neighbor's house I'm just gonna
go to another I'm gonna go to the
boutique I'm gonna go have my fun
[Music]
honestly it's kind of purely based off
of a tear that the feelings were genuine
I I would believe that feeling or maybe
that tear was coming because he was
going to hit him over there
I'm gonna beat you over the end baby I
thought I would have probably done that
yeah probably and then I don't know how
to work the Gap yeah yeah
just hit it not working in the Raider
show up I'm like oh God
Anna why don't you take us through some
games some things about this show that
are different from the game this episode
Really Got Away yes so and because hello
the idea of just not knowing how to use
the generator
I would have done
um because the show differs from the
game so much in this episode I'm gonna
put a little spoiler a little baby
spoiler warning right here we're going
to talk about the difference between
Bill and Frank in the game and here so
if you know if you truly want to play
the game blind yeah here's your good
morning you've been warned
um so yeah pretty pretty much this
entire episode is kind of new
information
um we never see Frank ever in the game
uh well okay we see his dead body in the
game thank you
um pretty much uh the differences are
insane yeah bill in the game is very
Brash very outspoken very sassy sassy is
probably not the right word because he's
not like flamboyant in any sort of way
considering the circumstances uh but
um he's very he's
dude he's just like loud he's loud and
bold
um and then not like Nick Offerman at
all and then we hear that his partner he
just references him as his partner uh
left at some point later we come across
Frank's Body that has been hung uh Bill
makes remarks that he has bite marks on
him and so Joel Joel also doesn't know
Frank at all he's never met him when
John alley get to the area bill is alive
this is still alive yes in the game yeah
yeah didn't well he went there because
he knew him though yeah because he was
getting them yeah he knows Bill he
doesn't know who Frank is no oh yes
show up bills there Bill's very mean to
L.A because Ellie keeps touching his
comic books yeah and uh bill is very set
in staying in the compound so he's never
ventured out of there they venture out
to go find a battery for the car and to
find the components the parts basically
and that's when they come across Frank's
Body that has been hung it has bite
marks um and so Joel's like it seems
like he didn't want to turn he hung
himself he was like cool later in the
house uh Joel finds a note from Frank
that says basically I hate you I would
rather you were always too chicken [__]
to leave the compound I didn't like that
life and you always said it'd get me
killed if I left but that's better than
spending another goddamn day with you
yeah and that is a happy of a woman I
genuinely love that note and I learned
and I loved it but that scene I was like
this is fun and then and throughout the
entire episode I was like
Frank's Not Gonna Last I was like
Frank's gonna leave and be very upset
when he leaves and that's why I was so
sketched out the whole time like knowing
that this is how the game version yeah
yeah that's why I was so sketched out in
the beginning I was like Frank
anyway uh you get he did Joel I think
you have to give the note to I've never
seen a playthrough where they don't give
a note the note to Bill and she will
share it with him yeah I don't know if
you if it's uh if you have to but uh he
shares a note with Bill and Bill's like
oh that's how you feel well [__] you too
Frank and they they never there's no
loving words exchanged ever except he
says he maybe cares for his partner a
little bit but no words are ever
exchanged and we actually pretty much
don't know that bill is even gay until
they are driving away in the car and
Ellie has snagged a uh a male nudie mag
from from Bill's room and she's like how
do they walk with that thing and I was
like and that's the first time we're
like oh they were Partners potentially
but they never uh outright say it and
certainly never see Frank alive so huge
differences there
um I will say the truck in the end is
kind of the same
they wind up in the game they leave that
area with with uh Bill's Truck yes they
they he's still alive when they leave
yes
so so huge huge things these are these
are such massive changes but I feel like
it's because they wanted to focus on the
relationships that they've always been
saying it's also the transfer from a
video game to a storytelling series for
people that have not played the game why
would you be so attached to Bill knowing
that he immediately is just like he's a
dick yeah yeah so this relationship I
like so much more but the entire time I
kept going no Frank's gonna die and then
when he got shot when Bill got shot I
went yeah Bill's gonna die yeah yeah and
I just kept going back and forth and
then when he was like I'm taking the
pills I was like okay so Frank's gonna
die
I think everyone has played the game and
like this episode was like shock After
Shock I don't know what's happening
anymore I'm totally where they're
strawberries strawberries
[Laughter]
um yeah strawberries a gay thing I don't
know look it up
um but I don't I it felt like it was a
good change because in the game I I
didn't like Bill yeah I probably felt
like Frank was probably Justified I
didn't know Frank but I was like yeah I
think more as a joke in the video game I
would say and this is a a much more
tender way to explore the concept of
love in this show bill was very silly to
me yeah when in the game I was like this
man's a little here's the media and here
it's like this is a serious relationship
here you have to live there and I love
just the way how they still got the
battery so they still got the battery
still got the batteries
and you guys make me think of it every
time you say it I'm always like yeah
Pascal did not say it that way go back
and watch the first episode around the
59 minute Mark Pedro Pascal gets the
line delivery that will win him in the
Emmy where he says I need the battery
tests
it's perfect I need the battery test uh
let's take over kill counts real fast
Joe zero no don't go into this at least
Ellie gets one kill a little infected
boy stuck under the the rubble I would
handicap her on this one yeah I would I
would say zero are we counting the in
fact oh my God she murdered that is true
she did stab it in the eyes I think no
no this episode
no no no two confirmed kills he
definitely killed some Raiders too uh I
think oh one was on fire the fire he's
definitely shooting some of them he's
got a rifle with a scope
electrified guy he killed that infected
in the woods the individual one that
went hit the tripwire are we counting
affected her arm yeah well I apologize I
think it's the way that the infected is
killed maybe counts because it's more
gruesome I need consistency in my life
he also gave Bill two kills which I
would not do why are we doing this
because are you counting himself as one
yes yes
self-inflicted he's unaligned John
doesn't count uh so now let's let's uh
this is your heavy heavy heavy spoiler
talk warning uh heavy heavy heavy we're
gonna talk about anything we want from
DLCs to Future games to part twos
whatever so briefly before we go Ellie
mentions this friend that knows
everything there is to know about Mortal
Kombat 2 when she comes across the
machine uh and left in the Left Behind
DLC uh for Last of Us the game Riley
brings Ellie to a busted arcade cabinet
for the fictional game the turning in
the game it wouldn't surprise us if that
ends up being like a Mortal Kombat 2
cabinet in the sad adaptation like Anna
was saying earlier there's a later
episode called Left Behind that's title
Left Behind that's probably where we'll
get into a flashback that goes into
Riley and Ellie and everything uh one of
the big scenes from the game that
happens with Bill is our first
introduction to a bloater in the high
school there's this whole side mission
where they go to try to find a truck and
they introduce to a bloater uh do you
think Joe and Ellie will have to
experience that alone or will the show
tweak the reveal of the bloater a little
bit like I
in the game it's big and fat yeah uh it
can throw Spurs yeah bombs at you is
this is the part where they saw one in
the trailer
oh there's a fire he's a chunky boy
chunky Boy comes out of the Flames so
I'm trying to think of where in the
story are there more Flames I can think
of them they might change it I don't
know
um it would be more dangerous if they
faced it alone yeah and also you would I
I would hate if they put it in the intro
but just didn't put it in this season oh
no no no no no no no you said at the
very end so I was like yeah
since we're officially in spoiler
territory now that I'm thinking about it
it might be when they uh introduce Henry
I will be so mad if that's the way Sam
goes uh is bio bloater because they got
a stage oh also Neil judgment the names
in this show in the game Sam Henry David
Jones it's easier
you just name them come on Jessica and
Ryan come Brandon uh one thing I was
wondering uh would you leave immediately
like they drive away pretty fast
they now have the mission
for Tommy now in Wyoming
I know but wouldn't you stay at this
compound for like a week I would say for
a couple days I'd be like there's no
race now also like Ellie downstairs with
all the guns and being like come on yeah
that was a little few more guys I don't
know I would stick around for a day or
two and have a couple good meals a
couple good showers and a couple good
shits on an actual toilet that's what
I'm talking about but then you're also
for getting like the I guess people act
their own way there isn't two dead
bodies in a room that's locked in that
house that's true because you go to the
neighbor's house but it's not as nice
that's nice
Resource Management resource that's why
Brandon shits into plastic bags then why
do you need a toilet
and that is it that is it toilet humor
is where I draw the line from Brandon
from Brandon anyone else can do it this
girl Mega jokes about uh the White Room
by Cream has a problem with my toilet
look here that's not toilet humor
okay that's it for the episode of the
break room we'll be back next week to
discuss episode four but we also do the
show every day live at 3 P.M talking
about all the nerdy news that you need
to know and that you love
Follow Me Lulu underscore Clemens follow
Brandon at Greenbrier grin and Barrick I
need to emphasize the r and Anna it's
Anna Vincent so much easier
subscribe to the break room wherever you
get your podcast and we'll see you guys
Tuesday thanks for watching bye
[Music]